- [Voiceover] A barista
poured a cup of coffee.
The initial temperature of the coffee
was 90 degrees Celsius.
At time t increased (laughs).
As time t increased, the
temperature C of the coffee
began to decrease exponentially
and approach room temperature
of 20 degrees Celsius.
Which of the following graphs
could model this relationship?
So we're starting at 90 degrees Celsius.
It looks like all of the graphs
start at 90 degrees Celsius
at t equals zero.
And we're going to approach
the room temperature
of 20 degrees Celsius.
So this first one does
approach the room temperature
of 20 degrees Celsius as t increases.
Now this one, when t is 70,
when t is 70.
I'm assuming this is in minutes.
When t is 70 it looks like
it has the temperature
going to zero degrees Celsius
so that cup of coffee is
going to start freezing.
So I think I can rule out B.
Also this looks like a linear
model not an exponential one.
C, it does get us to this end state
that stays at 20 degrees,
but it doesn't look like
an exponential model.
It looks like it's linearly decreasing
and then it stops linearly
decreasing after 50 minutes
and then it just stays
constant at that temperature
of 20 degrees.
So even though it gets
us to the right place,
it does not look like
an exponential decay.
So I would rule choice C out as well.
So A is looking good.
D, we are starting at 90,
it does look like an exponential function.
We have exponential decay right over here
and we are approaching something
but it's not the room temperature
of 20 degrees Celsius.
We're approaching 30 degrees Celsius here.
So I'd also rule out D.
So A is looking good.
It's an exponential.
It's decreasing exponentially.
Starting at 90 degrees Celsius
and it's approaching the room temperature
of 20 degrees Celsius.
Let's do another one of these.
So it says.
Let me scroll up a little bit.
So it says, after the
closing of the mills,
the population of the town
starts decreasing exponentially.
The graph below represents
the population, P,
in thousands, of the town t years
after the closing of the mill.
Alright.
So it looks like the
population starts at 40,000.
It's decreasing exponentially.
It looks like, over time, the population
is approaching 20,000 people.
So, what are the question here?
Based on the graph, with the mill closed,
what does the population
of the town approach
as time increases?
We just said it.
As time increases, it looks
like it's coming close to,
it's approaching, 20,000.
It's approaching 20,000.
It's already gotten
below 22,000 as far as,
you know, it looks like
after 20 or 22 years.
We've already gotten below 22,000,
so we're definitely below 30 or 40,000.
But we haven't gotten below 20,000
but we are approaching it.
We can even check our answer if we like.